Mời các đồng giến là nào với rại biểu phòng gặng hình nhân dân
theo dõi phòng biểu dễn thật bình, sửi tình hỗ trợ phục
có kính sĩ phó rất lành cạnh vệ, khi tránh kai bảo vệ
tổng thống Lức S, đi khăn quan khu dịch a,
bị mục nhóm, phần tử khổng mố,
có chăm mì bú chàng phó ngờ tấn công.
Tình hỗng đường ra để giết sau, trong cuộc khổ trình tầm chính thúc Việt Nam,
ngày máu người thẳng năm năm hành nhiên khu chà mày làm.
Tổng thống nước e quạt động tăng quan khu dịch a,
đúng mấy bốn dật của mày, bố tổ lệnh cạnh vệ
trên kai đợi hình xe vào vệ viếp xí trình đến vị trí thăm quan.
Đó sẽ gồm xe aning môt xe của viếp xe aning hai và xe của Lức Lệ gặp tiêng.
Chết xe, Lức Lệ xe quan kể vệ xe dạng tinh nghiệm được trong bị vú ki,
và cũng khu hối chợi nhận gạng đàn năng.
Khi biết số xe và gì kể vào khu vực thăm quan.
Bố tổ lệnh cạnh vệ chính kai đổi hình chính sĩ quan, kích phòng hảo vệ viếp.
Trong đó, có một sĩ quan tiếp tận trên và tâm sĩ quan tiếp tận căn cường.
Để ra đổi hình báo vệ có khả năng kiểm soát an ninh an quan cho viếp một cách cạc kẻ,
với khả năng phòng lửa và tấn công mạnh mẽ từ nhiều phía.
Nhằm đám báo an quan về tối cho viếp trong mọi tình hôn.
Số đặc trường dự vụ, sĩ quan bảo vệ tất cả lực nào tạo cơ bàn,
ở chỉ đổi vụ. Mình gặp tổ lệnh cắt cắt kè về phòng rất chính trị.
Đạo lức tế lực ngoại hình, con phải hội tụ, đây đồ cách ở tối như chỉ thông mình,
hình hình thông bó tổn, bánh xuống, bây lội, có chỉ đổi ngoại nữ và ăn vầy chính xách ngoại ra của đăng.
Nhà nước, phân hóa phòng tục tập quán của Việt Nam, cú nhu của các nước trên thế giới.
Chị cơ sở đó, vận dụ, liên hoàn, hiệu quả trong quá trình thường dự vụ.
Khiệp tời phát hiện các người cơ, đây gióa và để xuất miệp pháp dài quyết, nhằm bảo vệ tệ lỗi ăn toàn cho đất tựa đợi nghe bệnh trong bỏ tiền vụ.
Thì biết gì chỉ lần đến những thằng quan bất ngờ, đến nọng phục mốt,
sử dụng ngục xe em mùi sấu gói mang theo khu gàng hôm xung lũ đáng, lâu đến tấm không bao gọi hình bảo vệ, nằm dư dụi vệ.
Nhà nước, lưu lực sĩ quan bảo vệ tệ lỗi ím dụng, po hệ lời hình, sử dụng, ảnh trong đàn, chè, chẳng, cho vì mà ím dụi vệ, lưu vệ, quay trở lại xe.
Mùi nổi xuống, đưu vệ, mắm, phủ mơ.
Nên nơi ăn quan, lực lượng bảo vệ, phối họ vây lực lượng liên quan, bảo vệ hình dùng, phối họ,
phục bảo khẩm chất cho lực lượng ít tế, tế màu.
Đi tập, người để thường và đưa đến cho sợi tế, vật nhắm.
Khi tiêu các đủ chỉ, chủ đọc liên hoàn sáng tạo trong thực dạch dập vô,
trên nhật mẹ quét đoán trong sự lĩ tình hướng, nhiều chỉ giống cảm giác sàng ghi sình.
Vì dụng vô, cuộc sự phối họp tác chiến của các lựa ngồi liên quan,
cắn vô chế sĩ vô, tư lệ ngầy vệ, đã vào vệ tư tối ăn quan,
trong tổng thống ít, cho sự tổng thống hết sức mạnh đầu,
liều liên quan nhóm tội phạp cùng bố,
khẩn định ui tính của lực lượng cảnh vệ vệ hình Việt Nam.